el 1 de febrero de 2021 una profesora de
fitness estaba grabando uno de sus
entrenamientos en las calles de
naypyidaw la capital de myanmar de fondo
se pueden ver los tanques pasando y así
es como el mundo entero conoció el golpe
de estado de mi alma la pregunta es por
qué el ejército ha dado un golpe de
estado en mianmar y por qué debería
preocuparnos este país y el futuro la
democracia en mianmar en este vídeo te
lo vamos a contar y atentos porque
tenemos información de primera mano un
saludo a todos los seguidores de visual
polític soy pablo y trabajo y vivo en
yangon la capital económica de mianmar y
os voy a contar lo que estamos viviendo
estos días por aquí exacto en este vídeo
hemos tenido la ayuda de una persona que
está viviendo el golpe de estado de mi
alma muy de cerca como la situación
ahora es bastante peligrosa hemos
decidido ocultar su apellido para
preservar su anonimato dicho esto vamos
con el vídeo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y animales uno de esos países que todos
sabemos que existe pero que nadie se
habría colocar lo exactamente en el mapa
y es normal durante décadas han estado
totalmente aislados del mundo sí amigos
de visual política hasta el año 2003 ni
el mar era una especie de corea del
norte pero sin comunismo
[Música]
sin embargo en el año 2015 the economist
nombró a este país como el país del año
ese año y amar celebró sus primeras
elecciones libres y estas elecciones las
ganó esta señora que veis en pantalla
un samsung si ni nada menos que una
premio nobel de la paz podríamos decir
que esta señora es algo así como la
versión asiática de nelson mandela
vamos que hasta a los deudos la han
dedicado una canción por estos años es
cuando vine a mianmar buscando las
nuevas oportunidades que este país no
ofrecía ni al mar caminaba finalmente
hacia la libertad esta va a ser una de
las pocas democracias en el sudeste
asiático y había muchas posibilidades
dado que tras décadas de aislamiento en
este país está todo por hacer el país
tiene petróleo gas hubiese piedras
preciosas produce gran cantidad de
alimentos y además es precioso por lo
que tiene un potencial turístico enorme
sin embargo bajo este nuevo gobierno
democrático el ejército birmano el
llamado está armado perpetró un
genocidio contra una minoría racial los
rojillos todo esto con el apoyo tácito
de la premio nobel de la paz
llegó a defender al ejército en la
comunidad internacional y ahora el
ejército la devuelve el favor dando un
golpe de estado y arrestando la así que
la pregunta es por qué el ejército ha
dado un golpe de estado en mi amar hasta
qué punto este país puede recuperar su
democracia porque debería preocuparnos
ni al mar hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes antes os tengo que
dar toda una sorpresa algo que muchos
nos habéis pedido durante años
veréis desde que empezamos este proyecto
visual político nos habéis pedido que
demos más contenido sobre latinoamérica
y es normal a fin de cuentas hay muy
pocos medios que cubran esta región con
seriedad
apenas hay análisis políticos y
económicos sobre latinoamérica y esto es
especialmente preocupante si tenemos en
cuenta que se trata de una de las
regiones más impredecibles del mundo
pues bien os presentamos la tan política
la primera cuenta de su stack dedicada a
la política latinoamericana a partir de
ahora os enviaremos tres correos por
semana con los análisis más precisos
sobre latinoamérica
pero no sólo eso para asegurarnos que os
damos el mejor análisis de política nos
hemos asociado con una de las mejores
consultoras de inteligencia política en
el mundo berge perspectives esta empresa
asesora a varias multinacionales en eeuu
pues bien a partir de ahora todo ese
conocimiento estará disponible también
para todos vosotros y diréis pero cuánto
cuesta suscribirse a latam político si
se trata de un servicio de consultoría
que usan las grandes empresas seguro que
no va a ser barato pues nada menos que
cinco dólares al mes o cincuenta dólares
al año es más podéis probar las primeras
dos semanas totalmente gratis pero no
sólo eso los que nos apoyáis en el nivel
4 de patrián recibiréis la tan política
a coste cero y diréis pero como os
podéis suscribir a la tan política pues
muy sencillo sólo tenéis que entrar en
la tan polític puntocom elegir idioma y
suscribiros a la cuenta de su stack con
esto no sólo estaréis contribuyendo a
mejorar visual politics sino que además
tendréis el mejor análisis geopolítico
para vuestra toma de decisiones y ahora
sí vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
la guerra civil más larga de la historia
normalmente cuando hablamos de asia
pensamos en países emergentes como
vietnam o china países que eran muy
pobres hace 50 años pero que hoy crecen
a toda velocidad pues bien me amar es
todo lo contrario hasta mediados del
siglo 20 mianmar entonces birmania era
conocida como la perla del sudeste
asiático la colonia británica más rica
de la región tenía de todo minas de
rubíes de jade petróleo gas pero en el
momento en el que se independizaran las
cosas fueron de mal en peor veréis en
mianmar hay más de 135 grupos étnicos ya
os podéis imaginar lo difícil que era
que todos se pusieran de acuerdo tan
pronto como se independizaron muchas de
estas pequeñas etnias de mianmar se
rebelaron contra el nuevo gobierno
creando no una sino 15 guerrillas que
entre todas son prácticamente una guerra
civil la guerra civil más larga de la
historia porque empezó en 1948 y
continúa hasta nuestros días mirad este
mapa
este mapa muestra las zonas controladas
por los grupos étnicos minoritarios de
mi alma que buscan mayor autonomía y en
general una república federal son zonas
fronterizas que escapan del control
directo del gobierno central y del
tatuador el ejército y aunque la mayoría
de ellas se encuentran status quo es
decir que no hay conflicto abierto entre
grupos armados muchas de ellas funcionan
de forma autónoma con sus propias
fuerzas de seguridad impuestos y demás
para que os hagáis una idea en estas
zonas es donde se produce casi todo el
opio y la metanfetamina que se consume
en el mundo en otras palabras que es
donde están casi todos los grandes
narcos asiáticos
[Música]
y os preguntaréis pero y qué pasa en la
parte que no está en guerra qué pasa en
la parte que sí tiene un gobierno
legítimo por lo cierto es que las cosas
no van mucho mejor en un principio me
han mar tenía un gobierno civil pero en
1962 el general ne win dio un golpe de
estado y empezó una larga dictadura
militar
la diferencia de tailandia que también
ha tenido dictaduras militares durante
años los militares de mianmar se
caracterizaban por dos cosas la primera
el aislamiento absoluto durante décadas
mi alma estuvo cerrado a cal y canto a
la inversión extranjera
mientras tailandia recibía con los
brazos abiertos a las fábricas de coches
o de discos duros los militares de mi
andar querían estar aislados de todo el
mundo es más querían estar aislados
tanto de eeuu como de la unión soviética
esto explica por ejemplo que muchos
estados ni siquiera reconozcan el nuevo
nombre del país ni al mar es más si
buscáis este país en los mapas
encontraréis que siempre aparece con dos
nombres
birmania que es el nombre que tenía
cuando era una colonia británica y
mianmar que es el que le dieron los
militares y os preguntaréis pero qué
ideología tenían estos militares eran de
izquierdas o de derechas eran religiosos
o eran ateos pues nada de eso podríamos
decir que durante décadas me han mal ha
sido una dictadura militar astrológica
vamos que sueltas por ahí a sandro rey y
le hacen ministro queréis un ejemplo
pues os doy un ejemplo el general ne win
tenía un número favorito el 9 esto era
así porque se lo había recomendado un
astrólogo por eso de un día para otro no
se le ocurrió nada mejor que prohibir
todos los billetes con valor no
divisible por muebles
[Música]
es decir que sólo dejó en circulación
los billetes de 45 y de 90 kits y por si
fuera poco era la tercera vez que hacía
algo parecido es decir convertir el
dinero en papel de colores pero no sólo
eso cuál es la capital de mianmar
naypyidaw una ciudad que hace 20 años ni
existía se empezó a construir en el 2002
y en 2005 ya era la capital una ciudad
con carreteras gigantescas maravillosas
pagodas doradas y enormes barrios
fantasma y diréis porque construyeron la
ciudad aquí pues y también fue una
decisión tomada por los astros
como os podéis imaginar con semejante
programa de gobierno la economía de
mianmar no ha levantado cabeza hasta
hace unos pocos años mientras tailandia
o china han empezado a desarrollar
clases medias me han mar sigue siendo un
país pobre y todo esto pese a tener un
montón de recursos naturales como os
podéis imaginar a los birmanos no les
gustaban nada esta dictadura y esto nos
lleva a hablar de la gran heroína
nacional aún sang soo choo hija de uno
de los padres de la independencia
birmana y exiliada tras el golpe de
estado del 62 sin embargo en el año 1988
regresó al país apoyada por un montón de
ciudadanos que querían que entrara de
lleno en política y os preguntaréis de
verdad la junta militar estaba dispuesta
a perder su poder pues obviamente no en
realidad hubo un intento de organizar
elecciones libres ocurrió en 1990
los militares ganaron 10 escaños de 492
así que anularon los resultados y
volvieron al astro dictadura de toda la
vida mientras tanto aún sang soo choo y
estaba en arresto domiciliario y así
siguió durante 15 años
estando arrestada es cuando recibió un
premio nobel de la paz- un premio
sájarov de los derechos humanos ya hasta
una canción dedicada por u2 a diferencia
de venezuela o corea del norte la
dictadura de mianmar es una de las pocas
que no ha tenido a nadie que la defienda
y esto explica que incluso cuando me
amar quiso abrirse al mercado
internacional el mercado internacional
le dijera contigo no
y esto explica que a partir de 2003 los
militares anunciaran la llamada ruta a
la democracia porque vamos a ver cuando
tú te acostumbras a meter en la cárcel
opositores políticos no te creas y no te
creas que es fácil dejar el auto hacen
falta por lo menos 10 años o más y eso
nos lleva al año 2015 qué pasó en ese
año ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
la gran decepción en el año 2015 10
economist anunció que bien manera el
país del año y no era para menos tras 12
años de intentar traer la democracia y
al mar por fin celebró sus primeras
elecciones generales y el partido día un
sándwich y la llamada liga nacional para
la democracia se quedó con el 86 por
ciento de los escaños
[Música]
nuestra querida amiga su chino pudo
ocupar el cargo de presidencia y diréis
porque pues porque de nuevo esta ruta
hacia la democracia es muy larga y los
militares ya se aseguraron de que esa
constitución democrática de mianmar no
iba demasiado rápido en eso de la
democratización así es que pusieron un
párrafo que prohibía ocupar el cargo de
presidenta cualquiera que tuviera
familiares en el extranjero y diréis por
qué pues porque succi estaba casada con
un británico con esto yo os podéis hacer
una idea del poder que mantenía y
mantiene el temible está armado en el
país sin embargo una cosa es cierta mi
alma ya se había abierto al mundo de
hecho desde que se anunció esta ruta
hacia la democracia los militares
sacaron leyes para permitir la inversión
extranjera
para cuando su chi llegó al poder el pib
del país se había duplicado en diez años
mi ámbar estaba cambiando a toda
velocidad
de repente empresas como h&m inditex o
prime mark ya estaban montando sus
primeras fábricas por la zona y no sólo
hablamos de empresas occidentales
atentos a este mundo
china le encantaría poder tener un
puerto en el océano índico al que ya
tiene un puerto en bangladesh pero para
cruzar bangladesh tiene que pasar por la
india con la que cada día se lleva peor
sin embargo china también tiene frontera
directa con mianmar que podría ser una
salida mucho más fácil al océano y esto
explica noticias como esta si neymar
acuerdan acelerar la construcción de un
puerto clave de la franja y la ruta este
puerto en la ciudad de chía y view sería
el puerto de aguas profundas chino en el
índico pero además me han mar también le
interesa a la india porque es su acceso
natural al sudeste asiático en otras
palabras que oportunidades para crecer
no faltaban el problema el problema era
la democracia birmana además de prohibir
que sushi se presentara a las elecciones
el taimado se aseguró de no soltar el
poder ni con agua caliente por un lado
atentos fijaron por ley que se quedaban
con el 25 por ciento de los escaños del
parlamento y es prácticamente imposible
aprobar leyes sin su apoyo
una parte de los negocios en mianmar se
realiza todavía de forma irregular la
seguridad jurídica es la asignatura
pendiente para una liberalización de la
economía que permita al país desplegar
su potencia se necesitan menos
regulaciones y que éstas sean muy claras
para seguir atrayendo inversión
extranjera y poder generar una nueva
clase media pujante pero el potencial
desde luego está ahí sin embargo este no
es el principal problema de mianmar el
programa de este país siguen siendo los
derechos humanos en el año 2017 en una
provincia del oeste del país ocurría lo
siguiente
[Música]
cuarenta pueblos robinias quemados desde
octubre os acordáis de las 135 etnias
oficialmente reconocidas en mí al mar
pues los rojilla ni siquiera están en
esta lista se les considera refugiados
extranjeros así que me el mar no lo
reconoce como sus ciudadanos pero esto
es lo peor de todo lo peor es que se les
niega el acceso más básico a los
servicios más fundamentales y que el
ejército les está exterminando hecho en
general que ha liderado este golpe de
estado es el mismo general que inició el
genocidio
el general min aun line de hecho toda
esta campaña de odio contra los rojillas
se inició en facebook este señor porque
esto toda una campaña de facebook que
terminó con buena parte de los dos
hermanos apoyando el genocidio vigilia
los resultados son más de 25 mil
personas asesinadas por el ejército y
750.000 desplazados
y os preguntaréis cuál fue la respuesta
de la premio nobel de la paz que creéis
que hizo la nelson mandela asiática la
mujer a la que los mismísimos u2
dedicaron una canción pues nada más y
nada menos que presentarse en la sede de
la corte internacional de justicia para
defender
a los militares todo esto tiene dos
explicaciones la primera es que a un
samsung chino podía enfrentarse
directamente al ejército la segunda es
que por terrible y cínico que nos
parezca la opinión pública mi hermana
estaba a favor del genocidio rojilla de
hecho podríamos decir que su chip ha
sacrificado el apoyo internacional a
cambio de ganarse el aplauso de todo su
país y todo esto explica noticias como
esta
[Música]
las elecciones y en mianmar ofrecen otra
victoria decisiva para a un samsung si
esto ya es 2020 y el partido de anschütz
y obtuvo más escaños que nunca vamos que
me amar esta mujer es más popular que el
mismísimo bono de u2 entonces porque no
la quiere el ejército pues ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver
[Música]
el golpe del aerobic volvamos al
comandante en jefe del ejército birmano
el señor min aun line está a punto de
cumplir los 65 años y esta es la edad a
la que los militares de mi animal se
tienen que retirar sí o sí y diréis cuál
es el último nivel que le quedaba por
desbloquear a este señor exacto el nivel
jefe convertirse en presidente de mi
animal pero no sólo eso el ejército
tiene miedo de que su chip cambie la
constitución para quitarles del poder
con tantísima popularidad como tiene
esta posibilidad es cada vez más
factible así que sólo le queda un camino
el golpe de estado y como lo han
justificado pues el ejército ha dicho
que las elecciones fueron fraudulentas
aunque no han presentado ninguna prueba
al respecto y con esta justificación han
vuelto a tomar el poder por la fuerza
hasta aquí nada nuevo no es la primera
vez que el ejército promete más
democracia y luego da un golpe de estado
cuando ven que pueden perder el poder la
novedad en este caso es la respuesta
ciudadana
[Música]
en estado en mi amar los manifestantes
desafían las amenazas de los militares
con una huelga general el pueblo birmano
es en general pacífico y jerárquico lo
que explica que en el pasado se haya
convivido con autoridad durante largos
periodos de tiempo y el taimado del
ejército los ama sin embargo esta vez
parece que algo ha cambiado la nueva
generación que ha crecido con internet y
ha experimentado los primeros pasos del
país en la globalización ha saboreado ya
la libertad lo que es el crecimiento
económico lo que puede ofrecerles y esta
vez parece que no están dispuestos a
volver al sistema anterior en el momento
en el que grabó casi toda la economía de
mianmar está paralizada muchos negocios
han cerrado la gente está realizando
boicots a las empresas vinculadas al
ejército y se niegan a pagar el iva de
los productos
de hecho la cerveza más popular del país
era propiedad del ejército es rechazada
por el pueblo y ha sido retirada de la
mayoría de comercios de alimentación
incluso están pensando en formas de
dejar de pagar el impuesto de la renta
mientras tanto el ejército ha cortado
internet varios días para intentar
frenar las protestas que día tras día
une en la calle a miles y miles de
manifestantes de distintas etnias y
clases sociales
a los que les une el rechazo a la acción
del ejército y el apoyo al gobierno que
eligieron en noviembre
[Música]
por el momento indonesia y filipinas ya
están presionando el ejército para que
deje el poder
eeuu ya ha impuesto sanciones económicas
dirigidas al tornado y parece que la
unión europea va a seguir el mismo
camino la gran duda sobre estas
sanciones es y qué pasa con china si
estados unidos y europa vuelven a cortar
todos los lazos comerciales con mianmar
lo dejarían en manos de china al cien
por cien así que ahora la pregunta es
para vosotros es posible frenar el golpe
de estado en mi el mar que se puede
hacer para proteger la democracia en
este país podéis dejarme vuestras
respuestas en los comentarios
antes de terminar me gustaría dar las
gracias a pablo quien nos ha estado
ayudando en la investigación para este
vídeo pese a que ha sido realmente
difícil la comunicación por los cortes
de internet que ha impuesto el tramado
de nuevo recordad visitar y suscribiros
a latam polític y por supuesto no
olvidéis que aquí en visual politics
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas
así que suscribiros a este canal darle a
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones y si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like un
abrazo y nos vemos en el próximo
[Música]